[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump's travel ban is a
Muslim ban and his immigration
enforcement order is a purge of
Hispanics and I am tired of hearing the
radical right [ __ ] that they are
anything else and I do not believe a
word about them coming out of this
racists mouth
whether it's CPAC or this insane address
to Congress and most importantly they
are useless they add nothing to the
safety of this country they are sadistic
they're turning ordinary unthinking
Americans into a mindless Gestapo Donald
Trump's Gestapo when you detain an
American born in Philadelphia and ask
him over and over again where did you
get your name from and are you Muslim
and the man's name is Muhammad Ali Jr
it's a Muslim man when ice agents
reportedly wade across the street from a
Virginia Church refuge designed to save
the homeless from freezing to death on
our streets and you grab six men as they
leave the place
it is a purge of Hispanics when an
apparent white supremacist reportedly
asks two engineers from India in a bar
in Kansas City about their visas then
allegedly shoots them while shouting get
out of my country and Sean Spicer says
that the thought of it having anything
to do with Trump is quote absurd it's a
Muslim ban when you end a program
designed to prevent the deportation of
spouses and parents and children of
active US military personnel
it is a purge of Hispanics when you tell
the Oregon family of a four month old
girl that no no matter who approved what
when she is initially denied entry to
Portland for a life-saving surgery
because she's from Iran it's a Muslim
ban when you go into a Texas courtroom
and you grab a victim of domestic abuse
who was there getting a restraining
order and the tip may have come from the
alleged domestic abuser
it is a purge of Hispanics when you
detain a 70 year old woman and
interrogate her at LAX for two hours
because somebody somewhere thinks
there's something wrong with her
American
visa when there isn't and she turns out
to be the author of children's books
with titles like possum magic and with
love at Christmas and her name is Marian
ma'am Fox and this is their 117th trip
to this country and she says it's the
first time she has ever been questioned
let alone interrogated it's a Muslim ban
when you allegedly detain a Mexican man
at the border and even though he is in
apparent emotional distress you deport
him again anyway and he goes to a bridge
a few hundred feet into Mexico and he
throws himself to his death it is a
purge of Hispanics when you ignore the
report from the Department of Homeland
Security that the ban on travel from the
seven countries will likely do nothing
to enhance American security it's a
Muslim ban when you sees a man being
released on bail and detain him for
nearly three days and you tell him he is
an illegal immigrant and you were going
to deport him and you don't care that
his birth certificate and state ID say
he is from Puerto Rico which is part of
the goddamned United States of America
it is a purge of Hispanics when you
detain a historian a visiting scholar at
Texas A&M and formerly at Harvard and
Dartmouth for ten hours because he was
born in Cairo Egypt 62 years ago and he
was coming here to speak about the
French Vichy government that
collaborated with the Germans in World
War two and how all those lessons have
been forgotten it is a Muslim ban that
now tracks directly back to the Nazis
and when you propose loosening
employment requirements for hiring new
border agents congressionally mandated
requirements loosening background checks
loosening the use of polygraph tests
loosening entrance examinations and when
you tell passengers on board a domestic
flight from San Francisco to New York
that they need to produce quote their
papers or they will not be allowed to
get off the plane because you're looking
for somebody who has a deportation order
against them it is no longer just the
Muslim ban or just a purge of Hispanics
it is a series of acts intended to
terrify Americans into submission it is
a series of acts intended to silence
those who would object and turn them
into human sheep it is a series of acts
intended to turn respect for authority
into fear of Authority it is a series of
acts intended to give the rank and file
customs and ice employees both the false
sense that they are still doing
something moral and an appetite for
sadism and brutality on which
authoritarianism beads it is in fact a
series of acts of terrorism against the
people of the United States America and
Donald Trump it is your doing and in due
time you will atone resist peace